das ist jetzt nicht die wollen ja meine kundennummern der leute die wollen ja meine kundennummer
ich wollte gerade die kundnummer raussuchen aus meinem twitter history von unity media
und unity media hat wohl ihren account gelöscht und dementsprechend sind alle pn mit unity
media weg das ist irgend ein fake account wahrscheinlich ja na geil
in ihrer aufbewahrungspflicht sache ist die ich kann ihnen das jetzt gar nicht schicken
weil ich muss erstmal meine kunden kundennummer raussuchen die weiß ich jetzt auch so aus
dem kopf nicht ich muss erstmal in den zettel raussuchen dann möchte im kundensenter einloggen
und gucken was weiß ich was meine kundennummer ist alter geht mir das auch in sack also die
20 minuten habe ich auch noch so jetzt die 20 minuten halten wir auch noch so aus warum
48 fps weil es flüssiger ist als 30 fps und mit der gleichen bandbreite besser aussieht
als 60 fps 48 fps streamen bloß absolute feifett leute ich habe es mir auch nicht ausgedacht
dafür bin ich nicht feifett genug das erste mal habe ich das gesehen oder bin ich auf
die idee gekommen wo ich in den overwatch stream von siegal geguckt habe und da ist mir
aufgefallen die idee einfach die auflösung bisschen niedriger zu stellen und die freundin
bisschen runterzustellen und dafür ist es bei schnellen spielen schärfer ist eigentlich
richtig gut dann habe ich auch gemacht ich habe ja auch mal eine weile overwatch gestreamt
twitter dark ages stream nur einfach 1080 ich glaube das frisst twitch nicht genau wir
waren beim tablet wie steuerst du das tablet denn also funktioniert folgendermaßen so
ist es angedacht und eigentlich wollte ich das ja heute im stream programmieren wenn
uns unity media beziehungsweise war davon jetzt nicht laufenden strich durch die rechnung
machen machen würde folgendermaßen funktioniert das ganze auf dem sp 32 also sprich auf dem
was wir hier gerade programmieren dem da dem dem da dort haben wir einen sensor drinne
wie gesagt für wenn es klingelt ob der höre abgenommen wird und ob der höre also es kommen
zwei solche sensoren dran einmal höre abgenommen erster stock einmal höre abgenommen zweiter
stock und einmal hat es geklingelt so wenn der erkennt dass es geklingelt hat dann schickt
er eine mqtt nachricht schickt eine mqtt nachricht und meine heim automatisierung software registriert
das dass es geklingelt hat das klingt jetzt so als dauert eine weile aber das dauert das
geht innerhalb von von keine ahnung 50 millisekunden oder so das geht wirklich schnell also sprich
das ding erkennt ja sofort das hat er so gut wie keine verzögerung wenn es klingelt das
ist ja mehr oder weniger instant hier dass er das mitkriegt so dann schickt er eine mqtt
nachricht meine heim automatisierung check das wie gesagt 50 bis 100 millisekunden verzögerung
das ist wirklich so gut wie nicht existent dann sagt meine heim automatisierung ok ich
habe jetzt registriert das hat geklingelt was soll ich denn machen so und dann habe ich
dort hinterlegt trigger sprich wenn es klingelt dann schicke eine nachricht an die ios geräte
schicke eine nachricht an die ganzen android geräte die da registriert sind und schalte
die beiden tablets ein so und wie das tablet einschalten bzw schalte die beiden tablets
ein und die tablets machen dann auch was so und wie das mit dem tablet einschalten funktioniert
ist folgendes auf dem tablet ist einmal tasker drauf und einmal thermux das ist so ein linux
linux für android und ich hatte ich hatte am anfang erst komplett über tasker gemacht
aber tasker ist immer so ein rumgefrickel weil man da so viel rumklicken muss die ganze
zeit also ordentlich linux ist besser und ich schicke aktuell einen attp request an thermux
auf dem tablet und thermux passt das ganze noch ein bisschen und guckt ob das stimmt
und dann ruft es den tasker job auf der das display einschaltet da ist ein tasker hast
dir alles hast dir alles drinne von display anschalten bis display locken bis sonst was
so der taskerjob der macht display an also er kann es auch anlocken aber muss er in dem
fall nicht er macht display an und er switcht den browser einmal aus und wieder an was den
browser aus und wieder an switchen bringt ist dass die seite sich refreshed tasker kann
leider nichts essentielles ohne root ich komme komplett ohne root aus kein problem
das ist kein ding ich habe noch auto input installiert dass der den browser auf vollbild
schalten kann weil da muss ein klick simulieren tasker kann mittlerweile ziemlich viel ohne
root wobei es stimmt gar nicht ich habe dir miss erzählt ich habe da ich habe da ich habe
da tatsächlich root drauf aber ich habe das auf dem gleichen tablet unten auch laufen
und da habe ich keine root drauf also das heißt ich verwende nichts was root braucht
auf dem tablet was ihr hier sieht da habe ich wirklich root da habe ich mir nämlich
einen sujano gehen heißt nicht mehr wie heißt denn jetzt linage linage fragt mich nicht
was ist das neueste 13 irgendwas für fire hd 10 installiert und da musste man da musste
man routen vorher dass das funktioniert ja ich habe das hier installiert darf man das
hier überhaupt zeigen weil ich mein amazon und twitch und twitch ist ja amazon und fire
hd ist auch amazon aber warum nicht zeigt dir was ich da drauf habe android development
bann ist raus ja das da top 15.1 hallo oh nee ich glaube wo da vorn steckt wieder zu
oder auch nicht jetzt hat es funktioniert ich glaube weil man muss das richtige muss
das richtige finden das da habe ich glaube ich das habe ich glaube ich drauf weil das
hier hatten einen bug mit dem video playback genau das da habe ich drauf auf dem einen
das läuft gut das kann mehr oder weniger alles was das dockraum auch kann bloß ohne amazon
bloat drauf genau das ist das was ich installiert habe auf dem oben auf dem unten ich habe
zwei gegensprechanlagen ist ja ist ja logisch also macht ja mal wenn man zwei stockwerk
hat hat man ja eigentlich immer oben und unten eine gegensprechanlage oder so ein telefon
unten ist noch das stock fire os drauf und das geht auch mit tasker aber ich werde das
unten auch noch flaschen dann laufe ich nicht gefahr dass irgendwann mal einen ota update
oder so kommt wenn ich nicht aufpasse mit dem wlan und das ding geht auf einmal nicht
mehr richtig hast du selbst schon einmal ein android custom rom gebaut nein habe ich noch
nie gemacht habe ich bis jetzt auch noch nie den anlass für gehabt und auch nicht die
den zug da irgendwie zu verspürt das zu machen hat sie jemand von euch schon mal gemacht
so jetzt probieren wir eine sache probieren wir jetzt noch mal aus weil wir haben noch
kurz zeit wir programmieren es jetzt gerade noch mal schnell ein bisschen schöner und
zwar wir wissen jetzt ja dass die sensoren an sich funktionieren das heißt wir machen
das hier nicht in der loop das ist auch so eine sache die ich euch empfehlen kann wenn
ihr input abfragt das zeit kritisch ist also sprich es könnte jetzt ja sein wenn ich jetzt
hier abfrage ok hat es geklingelt und ich warte eine sekunde und jemand klingelt wirklich
nur kurz dass ich nicht gar nicht mit kriege weil einer geklingelt hat das kann ja sein
natürlich kann ich jetzt das delay einfach raus machen und die schleife so schnell flitzen
lassen wie ich will aber trotzdem ist es nicht so schön es wäre besser wenn man das quasi
hardware mäßig triggern kann so nach dem motto sobald dort egal wie kurz ein signal
kommt soll er was machen und das macht man am besten über den über den genau das macht
man am besten über den interrupt das macht man in ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das eine
arduino funktion ist oder eine espresso funktion ich glaube das arduino funktion das macht
man best über attach interrupt und das sieht jetzt ein bisschen kritisch aus aber es ist
in der bedienung wenn man es einmal gemacht hat eigentlich total einfach und zwar sagt
man welchen pin man haben will pin und zwar wollen wir haben pin 33 so also wir wollen
sobald pin 33 sobald pin wir machen mal kurz null sobald der pin nummer 33 so überlegen
changed dann wollen wir eine funktion aufrufen so und das gleiche auch sobald input nummer
23 changed wollen wir eine funktion aufrufen allerdings machen wir so wir nehmen mal hier
nicht change sondern wir nehmen mal es interessiert uns bei der klingel ja eigentlich nur wenn
es ausgeht also sprich wenn es von wenn es von eins zu null geht interessiert uns ja
eigentlich nur weiß gar nicht was es da noch für andere sachen gibt es gibt es uns da
sonst noch gucken was da sonst noch für weitere funktionen gibt low change rising falling
high falling interrupt wird getriggert wenn der pin von high auf low wechselt genau das
ist das was wir haben wollen also sprich haben wir hier unten gerade gesehen sobald es klingelt
dann geht dieser pin von eins auf null und dann triggern wir das hier und rufen die funktion
auf das ist viel schöner als hier in der schleife das ganze 30 milliardenfach abzufragen
in der hoffnung man erwischt rechtzeitig so und hier muss man so eine funktion angeben
die ausgeführt werden soll wenn eben das event hier eintritt man muss da allerdings
ein bisschen aufpassen ich zeige ich zeige erstmal wie man das wie man das nicht machen
darf wir können jetzt mal die wunderschöne c++ lambda syntax begutachten gibt ja kaum
was besseres und zwar anstatt jetzt extra funktion anzulegen machen wir das hier einfach
in line und da sagen wir ok wir legen eine variable für den sensor an die nennen wir
einfach mal bell oder so oder klingel wir machen jetzt so ein denglisch geschichte klingel
wird gesetzt auf so klingeln müssen wir natürlich noch anlegen das heißt keine ahnung
was magst du aber hier ist am start choose my name also wer das sagt der hat tatsächlich
nicht unrecht weil choose my name sagt jemand meinte mal zu mir dass die lambda syntax von
c++ voll geil und verständlich wäre der hat nicht unrecht man muss sagen ich finde die
lambda syntax in c++ richtig scheiße aber im vergleich zu allem anderen was in c++
drinne ist ist das noch das was mit am wenigsten scheiße ist also sprich es ist alles andere
ist noch so viel schlechter dass die lambda syntax schon wieder ganz ok ist ich wem wir
auch immer auf diese sache hier gekommen ist es ist schon ein bisschen eklig was das
jetzt macht ist es ruft diese funktion auf sobald jemand die klingel drückt also sprich
sobald der pin sobald pin 23 von eins auf null geht von high auf low geht dann setzt
der klingel auf true das können wir jetzt mal ausbilden ob das ganze funktioniert wir
waren jetzt das gleiche wie vorher mal serial print so und jetzt uploaden wir die firmware
das heißt wenn ich jetzt die klingel drücke gleich wieder sollte dann kommen direkt ans
ab ja es soll heute geben die mögen c++ es erschließt sich wird zwar nicht aber jeder
wie er mag jeder wie er mag auch wenn ich sie nachvollziehen kann muss ich alles verstehen
mir ist es unbegreiflich wie man c++ mögen kann c++ ist wirklich schon echt so verbrechen
an an der menschheit fast schon so jetzt holen wir mal die klingel klingel und gleich klingel
ich mal sobald er richtig gestartet ist achtung klingel jetzt wird geklingelt bäm hab doch
gesehen zack bäm ich hab es nicht richtig reingesteckt gerade deswegen kann es mehrfach
also ihr seht das ist auch ziemlich schnell ich mach grad also ob es mal bildlich auszudrücken
was ich gerade mit dem mit dem stecker mache dass ich simulieren kann was passiert wenn
man die klingel schnell drückt ist also im endeffekt mache ich das bei dem stecker gerade
weil also einfach jetzt nicht richtig rein und raus sondern einfach nur so so reinhalten
und ihr seht das das spämt das spämt total durch hier dass er das erkennt dass die klingel
gedrückt wird also man sieht wenn man das über den interrupt triggert dann kriegt er
das auch wirklich sehr schnell mit wenn was passiert so was man allerdings nicht machen
darf und da muss man ein bisschen aufpassen wenn man jetzt auf die idee kommt und will
hier größere logik drin abfackeln da würde ich euch von abraten weil wenn ich jetzt hier
drinne anfangen in so einem interrupt händler mqtt nachrichten zu verschicken oder den delay
zu machen das probieren wir mal aus wir machen es mal ein delay so es passt mal auf was passiert
wenn ich da ein delay rein machen so ein interrupt händler also erstmal muss ich die firma hochladen
und dann können wir uns das ganze angucken sebaro wer von uns studiert informatik oder
oder liegen oder hast du die informatik oder oder was physik informatik siehst du da müsste
gerade hier das doch eigentlich was sagen ne ich habe kurz an physik gedacht weil weil
das physik grill so jetzt passt mal auf was passiert lol denkst du man lernt im studium
so was nein nicht so was aber dass man sich unter dem delay was vorstellen kann ich weiß
es war debated so also mal gucken was passiert wenn ich jetzt jetzt nochmal die klingel anschließe
und wir sehen irgendwie funktioniert das scheiß warum geht das warum warum warum kackt er
nicht ab ok also ich habe jetzt was gemacht was man eigentlich nicht machen sollte und
zwar im interrupt händler den delay rein zu bauen das sollte eigentlich probleme machen
ich weiß nicht warum es jetzt keine probleme macht aber sollte problem machen das ist auf
jeden fall keine gute idee maxi96 twitch prime dankeschön huge sub also man sieht es funktioniert
ich könnte jetzt hier logik reinpacken in 500 millisekunden kann ich massig logik reinpacken
aber also ich würde ich das ist sehr unstable also ich würde gucken dass ich in so einem
interrupt händler so gut wie nichts mache außer vielleicht ein paar variablen setzen
weil das hier ist ist ist quasi hardware logik wenn du es so willst die auch da drauf reagiert
deswegen da muss keine cpu hier irgendwelche schleifen drehen um zu gucken ob der input
irgendwie ist das ist ziemlich low level so ein interrupt händler und wenn der zu lange
hängt dann startet sich die kiste neu was macht eckige klammer geschweifelt klammer
auf das ist eine sehr gute frage da hatte ich grad von dass was du hier quasi was du
hier siehst wahrscheinlich noch nie gesehen hast weil du es fragst ist die wunderschöne
lambda synthax von c++ die haben sich nämlich gedacht es ist eine gute idee anonyme funktionen
mit so einer komischen sache hier zu machen man hätte es ja auch mit einer gescheiten
synthax machen können aber das c++ cremium hat sich gedacht nee lass mal möglichst viele
zeichen die wir schon in bedeutung haben wiederverwenden lass es möglichst kryptisch machen aber das
ist ja eh das hobby habe ich das gefühl von von unserem c++ cremium cremium die müssen
das möglichst kompliziert machen das heißt wenn die eine auswahl haben nehmen wir eine
klare synthax oder nehmen wir eine kryptische synthax mit sehr vielen zeichen die schon
dreifache bedeutung woanders haben dann entscheidet man sich für die zeichen mit dreifacher
bedeutung also um das aber kurz kurz weiter auszuführen mond mond Everest also falls
ihr nicht sagt was was was was lambda funktionen bzw lambda aufruf oder eine anonyme funktion
ist oder sonst was ist ganz einfach gesagt an der stelle hier könntest du auch eine
funktion hinschreiben zum beispiel sowas hier woid blub so ops wenn ich jetzt kann
ich mal schreiben woid blub dann kannst du anstatt dem lambda kannst du da auch eine
funktion reinschreiben dann würde er nein woid nicht was mache ich denn blub so dann
würde das auch funktionen dann würde der jetzt quasi blub aufrufen weil funktionszeiger
döns von c das hier ist bloß die kürzere variante im endeffekt anstatt sich eine extra
funktionen brauche kann ich die funktion einfach auch in line an der stelle schreiben was
er machen soll anonyme funktion deshalb weil die heißt halt nirgends die hat halt kein
name einfach hier funktion an der stelle und gut ist das bietet sich an für sachen
die halten die nicht sonderlich komplex sind also ich mache hier nix anderes außer eine
variante zu setzen in c++ ist die syntax dafür nicht sonderlich schön ich finde in dem fall
tatsächlich die java script schreibweise und die schreibweise relativ relativ hübsch
die die pyson schreibweise gefällt mir gar nicht die schreiben lambda aus die ruby schreibweise
ist auch recht schön also mal zum vergleich c++ macht das so in c sharp wird das ganze
so aussehen mal kopieren wir das einfach mal tue jetzt mal als wäre das ab in c sharp
wird das ganze so aussehen dass man sagt das da so nachdem es nur eine zeile ist könnte
man auch gleich so machen das wäre in c sharp erlaubt vollkommen in ordnung aber c++ hat
sich c++ kremium hat sich gedacht das brauchen wir so und noch schöner wenn man ein parameter
diskaten will kann man das in c sharp so machen oder hätte man so was kurz und knackiges
hier stehen aber das mag das c++ kremium nicht das das ist zu klar so und die java script
schreibweise sieht mehr oder weniger genauso aus die ruby schreibweise wäre glaube ich
wenn ich es noch richtig aus dem kopf zusammen bekomme so nee so wie war die ruby schreibweise
noch mal ich weiß nicht mehr ich habe zu lange keine ruby zeug mehr gemacht wo das
ist was das habe ich nie verwendet das da meine ich das das da meine ich eigentlich
das ist ja das ist ja auch übelst hässlich normalerweise sind so sachen in ruby immer
ganz gut aus naja so ich hoffe frage beantwortet wenn ich kannst du ruhig noch mal ein chat
schreiben wir haben ja noch kurz zeit 22 so also interupt getriggert wenn es klingelt
und also ich würde euch empfehlen nicht im interupt das handling zu machen von diesem
event sondern das hier in der schleife zu machen jetzt könnte man nämlich gucken hier
wenn klingel true ist dann machen wir was und am ende setzen wir klingel wieder vor
also nach dem motto event event gehandelt ich ich bin mal so ich bin mal so frei und
wir nennen das mal wenigstens in was ist schöner namen bell nee wie nennt man das ring was
heißt was heißt doorbell doorbell was denn jetzt kann ich das nicht umbenennen monka
xs hd das ist zu advanced für die sprache sachen umzubenennen ok verstehe fuck einfach
so variablen unbenennt das geht ja nicht das kann man nicht machen in c++ warum schreibst
du kein essen die bei uns da brauchst du ja kein loop an der stelle also ich bin mir
nicht ganz sicher was du meinst also ich weiß dass du eben die bei uns meinst da du musst
einfach gucken dass der kram wenn es irgendwie fünf mal getriggert wird dass es dann halt
nicht fünf mal die aktion auslöst sondern halt nur einmal alle was wir haben zehn sekunden
oder so was du mit dem essen die bei uns meinst weiß ich nicht genau aber ich muss
es nicht die bei uns weil die klingel witzigerweise schon in die bei uns drin hat also die löst
selbst nur einmal alle 30 sekunden aus also die schickt hardcoded von dieser klingel nur
einmal alle 30 sekunden diesen diesen diesen diesen klingel telefon ich habe geklingelt
impuls ich weiß nicht wie sie es genau gemacht haben aber ich habe es ausprobiert wenn ich
klingel es kommt genau einmal ins signal und dann 30 sekunden nicht mehr egal wie oft ich
klingel und egal wie schnell ich klingel wahrscheinlich hatten sie das gleiche problem dass ihre
ja dass ihre telefone rum gespackt haben oder so vielleicht haben sie das deswegen schon
eingebaut aber du kannst mir ruhig was meinst du denn mit einem essen die bei uns
essen gleich noch drei ja was ich habe ich kann mir da aber jetzt hier kodemäßig nichts
drunter vorstellen was du dir da drunter vorstellst meinst du sowas wie sowas so eine so eine
essung weight geschichte ich weiß nicht ob das das arduino c++ zeug kann und ich habe
auch keine ahnung wie man essen in c++ verwendet gibt sowas standard essen keine ahnung hat
das überhaupt sowas tatsächlich monka es ich liebe diese funktion von c++ die sind
immer so auf den ersten blick einfach zu erkennen was sie machen exzellent richtig
exzellent immer include future braucht man dann reiter was ist was ist mit den was ist
mit den schäb was ist mit den c++ leuten im kopf eigentlich los ja für future heißen
die dinger future oder promise das ist aber standard dass sie so dass das heißt überall
so max hast du überall ja sie bauen das heißt überall so future oder promise das ist das
ist tatsächlich mal normal dass es so heißt max hast du überall in deinem haus arduino
c++ verteilt überall im haus nicht aber ich habe schon paar wie gesagt wir hatten noch
hier letztens wir hatten noch letztens ein dokument wo wir uns aufgeschrieben haben wo
ich alles was verteilt habe raspberry mäßig genau also für die kamera am hoftor haben
wir den raspberry pi 0 mit der kamera drin für die statistik sammeln an der heizung
für statistik sammeln an der heizung haben wir den raspberry pi im keller dann haben
wir den octopie am 3d drucker wir haben ein android hc2 für fernsehaufnahmen und videos
gucken das ist zwar kein raspberry geht aber geht aber in die gleiche richtung dann ist
ein raspberry pi für den unify controller und die kameraüberwachungs software die wir
auch teilweise im stream gebastelt haben so so viel zu den raspberries ich hoffe ich habe
keinen vergessen aber ich glaube nicht habe ich noch irgendwo ein vergessen ja hier habe
ich noch ein raspberry pi 4 rumstehen für spiele rein aber der macht nicht wirklich
was der dient der dient im stream immer wieder zum ausprobieren von dingern habe ich noch
irgendwo ein raspberry vergessen glaube nicht so und so sps habe ich auch noch ein paar
sps habe ich kann man auch klein mal aufschreiben ich habe einen sp die werde ich aber alle
wohlgemerkt alle durch sp 32 ersetzen ich finde es einfach mittlerweile deutlich angenehmer
mit sp sp 32 was zu machen als mit sp 266 also ich habe einen ist auch egal machen wir
mal für beide ich habe einen stromzähler stromzähler hallo strom strom z äh what what the fuck
eine wim magic stromzähler ich weiß nicht was da manchmal passiert auf die kiste richtig
gemapt oder so also am stromzähler ü geht ü geht ok wunderbar stromzähler für erdgeschoss
und ähm erster stock das ist einmal so ein alter zähler mit so einer drehscheibe und
einmal einen mit ähm so led das heißt an dem esp ist einmal einen line sensor der checkt
wie oft die scheibe vom vom drehzähler durchläuft das ist wirklich big brain konstruktion
ich habe es mal hier kurz gezeigt im stream von der weide und ne ne ne ne ne foto photoresistor
der quasi erkennt wenn die led angeht so dann habe ich am stromzähler dran dann habe ich
ein esp 32 an am an der eingangstür der misst den äh wassergehalt von den pflanzen auf
der terrasse das macht er über solche dinger mi flora flower care die würde ich nicht
bei amazon kaufen viel zu teuer viel zu teuer die kriegt ihr bei banggood teilweise für
15 euro irgendwie 8 stück oder so das ist das ist viel also das ist er sagt ihr müsst
auf jeden fall bei einem asia zeug kaufen banggood banggood ist keine pornseite banggood
ist ein china shop auch wenn sich das so anhört als wäre es eine pornseite mi flora
ganz schön teuer ganz würde ich würde ich so nicht würde ich so nicht kaufen würde
ich gucken dass ich bisschen günstiger kriege also ich habe die wirklich im 5er packen gekauft
und da war die nicht teuer so also einmal mi flora sensor auslesen esp 32 an einer eingangstür
das funktioniert über bluetooth bluetooth low energy bluetooth das macht das dann habe
ich einen an der am hof am hoftor habe ich einen der hat einfach nur einen einfach nur
einen schalter dran der erkennt wenn hoftor auf und zu geht das ist auch ein esp 32 fire
beetle bord mit batterie dann kommt demnächst noch einer an briefkasten der ist aber noch
nicht dran da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher wie ich den machen werde vielleicht machen
wir den auch im stream da habe ich da habe ich schon ein paar ideen zu wie man das machen
könnte also zu checken ob der briefkasten auf und zu geht und ob im briefkasten was
drin ist das könnte man einmal mit die low skill variante wäre mit einem schalter am
deckel viel cooler wäre es mit so einem ultraschalt sensor oder sowas zu gucken ob was drinne
steckt im briefkasten das muss ich aber noch irgendwann mal im stream basteln aber weiß
ich nicht wie man das genau machen dann habe ich ein da sagt er das stream immer ich hab
es nicht mal dann habe ich ein boden bodenfeuchtigkeit sensor auslese ding auch in esp 32 fire beetle
ich erzähle jetzt nicht wofür er genau ist weil sonst er sagt das stream wieder ich
hab sie nicht mehr alle aber die die das schon öfters dabei war die wissen wo es ist das
stream länger als 22 jahre ich muss gleich ins bett was haben wir sonst noch so mehr
fällt mir gerade nicht ein reicht auch oder er hat der bär genau mit ja hat man du hast
du hast ipv4 adressen bekommen klar und da haben die auch nicht solche geschichten wie
natt gemacht du hast wirklich eine ganz stink normale ip range zugewiesen bekommen ganz
am anfang gab es ja noch nicht mal sowas wie subnetz geschichten das ist die geschichte
mit den laura dingern genau du hast früher einfach eine ganz normale ip range zugewiesen
bekommen ja ganz ganz früher noch vor meiner zeit ja so reicht jetzt also lasse ich mal
auf weil die frage kommt öfters bitte nicht vergessen upload teil hochzuladen ich schreibe
es mir auf falls nicht falls ich echt vergessen sollte dann also ich mache ich mache neues
repo ich mache neues repo bei mir auf github da lade ich rauf das meme tut spaktrum falls
ich vergessen sollte gehen wir noch mal im nächsten stream auf den sack dann lade ich
direkt da hoch ja gab es gab es im chat eigentlich auch der antwort was diese essen geschichte
angeht oder essen essen essen essen essen kronen wie spricht man das eigentlich richtig aus
es ist synchronis synchron leider nicht ja wie gesagt eure fragen sind nicht sind nicht
weg ich habe hier mein tool was die fragen mit lockt die gucken wir uns das nächste mal
an da ist nichts vergessen benutzt du ein spezielles tun für notizen ja ich verwende
das hier ach nee ich bin auf meinem streaming account das hier verwende ich mit mit next
cloud zusammen also wirklich glücklich bin ich damit nicht ich verwende in letzter zeit
versuche ich umzusteigen auf das hier weil das komplett cross platform ist ios android
windows linux mac os das versuche ich gerade in letzter zeit mich daran zu gewöhnen morgen
wieder streben ja ich hoffe unity media macht mit one note alles in baro es geht so was geht
das kann man wirklich machen in t plus plus hat ein essig away drin ich glaube nicht dass
ich das einfach benutzen lässt das ist bestimmt eine komplett ekliche ekliche sache ist wahrscheinlich
gar nicht drinne ich mein guckt euch mal gibt es wirklich irgendjemand von den c plus plus
bros also nicht bros sondern bros der hier drauf guckt und sagt ah yes excellent jetzt
weiß ich genau die für die funktion definiert ist gibt es wirklich leute die da drauf gucken
und sagen ja logisch jetzt wo du sagst was soll das sein alles machen die da du kannst
ja beide was mit einer deiner domains off ist rad 65 account erstellt ich will kein off ist
rad 65 account was soll ich mit off ist rad 65 e ist doch ich verwende keinerlei office
produkte wenn ich nicht dazu gezwungen werde stimmt und außerdem ist es microsoft rad
65 richtig man muss ja korrekt sein die haben sich auch bei microsoft gedacht ja die leute
haben jetzt verstanden dass es off ist rad 65 heißt zeit es wird zeit das ganze umzubenennen
dazu kann ich nur sagen so leute es war schön dass ihr dabei wart ich muss jetzt echt pennen
morgen wieder 37 homeoffice start ich bin ja schon froh dass ich überhaupt homeoffice
machen kann auch immer noch und wahrscheinlich auch eine weile warum zum teufel ist das ziel
mit 48 fps weil 48 fps deutlich flüssiger ist als 30 fps und es bei gleicher bitrate
schärfer aussieht als 60 fps also eigentlich richtig exzellent mach mal ein youtube video
zu homeoffice und korona ist jetzt gut zu korona habe ich mich schon mal ausgelassen
zu homeoffice wollte ich noch eins machen zu homeoffice wollte ich noch eins machen mich
über unfähige leute auslassen die selbst nach über zwei monaten immer noch geschissen kriegen
mal ihr hättet zu muten ja vor korona habe ich mich zu homeoffice ausgelassen sondern
habe ich gehts auf wir sehen uns morgen wollte ihr outro musik haben wahrscheinlich ich mach
noch mal die outro musik komm outro musik gut ist outro musik alles klar also leute wir
sehen uns machts gut vielleicht bis morgen ich denke mal bis morgen mal gucken ich bin
in letzter zeit wirklich oft am stream so bis denn und ich muss mal gucken warum die
bei der twitch tv mouse nicht funktionieren na gut bis denn machts gut
so
der
die
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute. Bis zum nächsten Mal.